What's up everybody!
I'm Emil from Pongfinity
And welcome to another episode of Challenge
Pongfinity!
This is the series where YOU challenge US
WIth your craziest ideas related to table
tennis.
We will go through all of your comments, pick
the most creative ones and make a video out
of them.
If your idea gets picked, we will feature
it and give it a shout out.
So make sure to leave your ideas in the comment-section below!
Anoshka Pande wants us to place a bottle on
the edge of the table
And hit the bottle with a ping pong ball to
make it flip.
Tirmisyu Trs wants me to spin a coin with
a ping pong ball.
This time I will try to do it with a serve.
Madison Cerat wants me to put 6 cups on the
table
- I have made a pyramid out of them -
and I'll have to do 6 different serves to
land the balls inside the cups.
Madison, let's do this!
Joe Pitt wants me to eat a whole meal while
keeping the ball in the air with my paddle.
Now the burger is down, but I think the worst
part is still ahead.
I lost my concentration for a tenth of a second
and then that's how it goes!
O well, that was the first one.
Okay now even the fries are down, so just
have to finish the drink.
So close!
Okay that was the second fail.
Let's finish this now.
Alright, so that was 2 fails.
I'm a bit disappointed I have to say, but
actually it's not too bad.
It's so difficult to focus on many things
at the same time.
Thanks for watching guys!
If you enjoyed this episode, make sure to
leave it a thumbs up.
And if you are new to the channel subscribe
right here.
And watch the previous episodes here!
Until next time!